can you talk about the excitement you
have now that it's time to go into
training camp when there's so many high
expectations and also I'd like for you
to talk about what LeBron said when he
talked about how everything should go
through you to make you feel so much
more important there Steve yeah
I'm excited just to get started
can't waste it tomorrow you know to be
around these guys and knowing that we
are gonna be a step closer you know it's
a tipping it off for real so I'm excited
about the opportunity you know to work
with his coaching staff to be here and
then but what LeBron said very very kind
of him you know you know we're gonna
know I think feed off each other
tremendously you know I think we're two
guys with very selfless and just want to
win and we have two guys like that makes
both of our jobs a lot easier and then
we also have other guys around us who
who also who know wants to win is gonna
help us along the way
hey Anthony focusing on the offensive
end just considering LeBron and the
attention that he draws defensively what
do you think that can do for your game
that you haven't had in the past just
with the you being the primary focus
most times in the defense I think it
opening up the floor it opened up
opportunity for other guys you know he's
always been a guy that commanded double
teams and he's also a great passer at it
I did a double team so I think you know
about him
you know commanding double Sampson it
was opened up my game up a lot a lot of
one-on-ones and single coverage defenses
and I also been able to you know swing
it to the next guy who might be open as
well so I think it for the defense in
the barn when you have two guys who you
have to worry about every time got a
floor
ad of rayet had what was your reaction
when you heard about the Marcus's injury
and and what would have been your
interactions with Dwight
since he's been able to come aboard I
was I was shocked just knowing that he
worked so hard to try to get back from
his ACL
I mean his quad and his Achilles you
know he hasn't no really had opportunity
to it'll be Oh DeMarcus and he wanted
this year to be the year because he felt
like he was very healthy and then you
know the ACL happens so he's in good
spirits he's happy too just to be here
still and be around a team and we
support him
all the way through and you know mid
Dwight very cool no he's been here since
he signed here you know working out and
we've been you know working out together
as well along side you know Jo so just
trying to you know get acclimated with
each other knowing that you know a lot
of times two of us are probably on the
floor together so I'm just trying to you
know build that team chemistry anthony
meaty days are always kind of weird I'm
gonna guess that this is a slightly
different experience than what you had
in New Orleans but when this is over
it's going to continue them and all
these people are very interested in the
Lakers and the Clippers so what do you
think that this experience will be like
for you going forward how do you think
it'll be different than me but what you
experienced in New Orleans a lot more
people here but I mean media today media
today you know everyone wants to get a
story
I don't everyone talk to the players
take pictures and stuff like that so it
doesn't faze me what I'm interested in
is you know the stuff we do on the floor
obviously the bigger city there gonna be
a coverage but you know I knew that you
know when I got traded here so I'm
prepared for that and my paint it's
gonna be a fun year Anthony just to your
right over here it's all good so the
Lakers have a storied history of big men
who have done great things on the court
but have also become stars it's really
in movies and TV as well you think of
wilt
shock those guys have all won
championships and also become movie
stars as a result you sort of see
yourself within that context given your
success in the NBA so far what you want
to do with the Lakers and now being in
Space Jam that was a one-time thing I
don't see that was a lot of that was
very time-consuming at least right now I
don't see any more movies it's a lot
near future but it was a fun experience
you know to be able to star almost a
star but being a movie you know that I
that I grew up watching my childhood so
I want to be you know especially I'm too
with other other players as well I think
it's a big honor for me and something
that I often always and hold on to
forever
ADT right this is obviously an iconic
franchise with a national brand how do
you keep your world small so you guys
can grow as a team and accomplish some
of the high expectations that come along
with this I think just knowing that
nobody outside our locker won't matter
there's gonna be a lot of stuff people
say gonna be a lot of narrative that no
people shot a tag on the Lakers but we
have to make sure that you know with all
that being said we have to stay close as
a unit from the player to the culture
instead of front office it has to be
just about the Lakers organization and
that's it and if we have to do that then
a lot of stuff that gets put out in the
media or try to portray the Lakers to be
something for try to portray a player to
be something that they're not we can
overcome that Anthony to your right a
little bit too right oh man has LeBron
spoken to you at all about you know what
it's like to play under the spotlight
that comes with playing on those teams
the pressure is that something that you
guys would talk about it or not
something you would address no he told
me anything but I mean you see I mean
it's how you playing under no big lights
night night out or someone's no not
someone but everybody's watching you not
a night out
like I say you're gonna hit obstacles
you're gonna have adversity you're gonna
have a narrative around you but it's
about how you overcome that and I think
we have it same that's as you know very
tight what we can lean on each other and
just put all that behind us ad right
here to your left
yes hi I know that she kind of make it a
point to forge strong relationships
whether it was with Drew in JA you know
working out over the summer
what was that kind of juxtaposition you
know working out with them and then
forging this new relationship with your
new team and how what kind of things did
you glean from kind of balancing those
relationships um those relationships
extending way more in the basketball
I've been knowing JA since I was in high
school you know he's from Chicago as
well I've been knowing drew for a while
you know no one but those those
friendships and all the relationships
extend off the court as well so it was a
easy transition that we still talk you
know and then also bring in you know
coming here and having building new
relationships with the guys here so in
all the relationships I have extend more
than just you know on a court so it
makes my record I easier hey I wanted to
ask about the players camp that you guys
had what was the energy like and and
what was LeBron like what kind of what
roles in each of you take during those
few days um it was fun I mean we had
some great workouts just trying to build
some team chemistry before going to
training camp it's the first time we had
everyone scuse me everyone's together
it's the first time we had everyone
together so that was pretty cool and
enjoyed each other's company and just
you know just have one last while before
you know training camp starts so I said
we got we got something working enjoy
Vegas and now ready get started
ad can you describe what your role was
during the offseason assisting the front
office and helping to recruit players
conversations you have with others and
the vision that you gave guys as as they
were seeking to join you guys with the
Lakers I think the front office did a
great job of including you know LeBron
of myself and the decisions you know to
build this team you know every guy that
is on this team know me LeBron had to
say so and I think that's very important
you know when you know you're going to
war with odds every day it'll be pretty
weird to go with a guy go to war with a
guy that you don't really like so you
know they make sure they want to include
us in every decision and then you know
it wasn't really a vision I just told
guys I mean you know we definitely have
our opportunity to do something special
here they're here and all you can ask
for is a chance in this league and we
definitely have a chance to do something
special when you know a lot of guys
actually was texting me and viewing the
ground I can I join so it was pretty
easy on my end but there there was guys
that we had the Charter you know
convinced that we really wanted here to
end up you know being here and now that
we have we feel like we have all the
right pieces to to do what we want to do
and reach I was gonna go now it's about
just going out you know buckling down
there doing it Anthony obviously I mean
you're gonna yes pups all year but for
agency next summer what if the Lakers
don't have done so far do you feel like
to give you a Simone ership in what's
happening here and then what has to
happen this year do you think to make
this a place you want to be long term I
just want to focus on this year you know
coming here you know the lake could
definitely open we were welcomed on well
open arms and made me feel like this is
home you know by the same time you know
it's about what we can do this year you
know we have a special team especially
the only special coaching staff and you
know we're gonna do whatever you can to
you know focus on this year and try to
come out victorious